the key thing that marginal analysis
helps us solve is what is called the
water Diamond paradox so you will die
without water we all need water and yet
water is dirt cheap whereas diamonds are
extremely Superfluous nobody needs them
um nobody's gonna live or die because
they have a diamond and yet they're
extremely expensive so why is it that as
human beings we pay maybe say a dollar a
liter for water whereas we pay thousands
of dollars for a few grams of diamonds
why is this the case do we value water
less than Diamond the answer is no but
at the margin where we are right now you
live in a place where water is very
abundant because the cities are only
built in places where water is abundant
and
um
you're only making a choice about the
next unit of water and so water is
extremely abundant and you're choosing
about whether to spend the next unit of
money on water the valuation that you
give to water given that you have a lot
of water at home
and that you live in a place that has
abundant water is pretty low to the
marginal unit
but it's very high for water overall so
if I asked you how much would you spend
for water in general you know how much
would you uh pay for water for all of
your life it would be a lot higher than
diamonds if I told you you can only have
water or diamonds for the rest of your
life you choose water obviously but you
nobody's ever had to make that choice
you only make your choices at the margin
so at the margin where we are in modern
civilization we have an abundance of
water that's why we have civilization
and diamonds are very rare and scarce
and um people are only buying you know
you buy your first diamond when you're
gonna get married and you give it to
your wife and that's that's going to be
the first few grams of diamond that
she's ever gonna I'm giving my wife
water
smart move you should definitely give
her Bitcoin instead of diamonds I tell
my wife I occasionally remind her what
the what week how many Bitcoin we could
have had if I bought her Bitcoin with
the price of the diamond what's the
downside of by the way diamonds for from
the analysis of like gold and so on ah
it's a great question
um arguably Diamonds Are a scam uh
because they became popular as a thing
in marriage after gold was banned after
gold ownership was banned in the US in
the 1930s and in many places around the
world so before that you'd give gold and
the reason you'd give gold in a dowry in
a wedding is because you know it wasn't
just that it's pretty and shiny it's
because it's money and so
um you know if you die or your wife can
take the gold and she can live off of it
um it's it's a demonstration that you're
giving her something valuable and that's
because nobody can make a lot more gold
that has the high stock to flow ratio
but then they banned gold ownership or
they allowed people to only own very
tiny quantities of gold and that's when
the diamond industry stepped in and
marketed diamonds as
um you know the thing that you need to
give but the problem with it is of
course that diamonds aren't like gold
they're not very hard to make more of
and the reason we have uh scarcity in
diamonds is really artificial there's a
there's effectively a monopoly of
diamond producers they restrict the
supply
and um it's a pretty dirty business and
the way that they do it is you know all
the um all of us talk about
um blood diamonds is a way for them to
ensure their Monopoly so
um if you're part of the Monopoly of
diamond producers then doesn't matter
how many people get killed producing
your diamonds if you're out of the
Monopoly then human rights organizations
descend on you and and call for shutting
you down for selling blood diamonds and
they're also restricting the production
of artificial dimes this is other thing
you can make artificial Diamond you
can't make artificial gold
so they restrict the production of
artificial diamond and they try and
insist that you know you shouldn't take
artificial diamonds but they're
indistinguishable from real diamonds so
it's an artificial scarcity and I think
there's going to come a point at some
point that this Monopoly is going to
break and a lot of people are going to
be left with uh essentially uh highly
devalued uh jewelry I'm going to take
this segment of the podcast when I'm
getting married when the sun did and
then instead you're getting water or
Bitcoin yes water and Bitcoin is all you
need